welcome to this video presenting
coverage of tata steel round eight round
eight plate today and again around
without any short drawers or
uninteresting games it was a big big
fighting round again so really
interesting tournament up to now and I'm
going to show all the games like before
and the chosen chosen the chosen order
of presentation is just by um yeah the
order of the tournament yeah how did say
yeah this the like is listed on the
tournament website so I'm not presenting
it in Anna any order of uninteresting
games first or then the best one as the
final game I'm just going through the
list as it is hard to to any sort of
from ya classification of one game being
more interesting than the other so let's
let's start one vini against nida CH the
Dutch German do album and turf and
Villiers playing defaults usual open
again tonight is playing the book win
yet would she rather often employs but
after a bishop d2 he somewhat
surprisingly chill on d 2 and this is a
good line for black am I mean the solid
satisfactory aligned it's not an
advantage for black of course but
knowledge usually goes forward c5 here
or sometimes a 5c five versus may move
and this is a much more fighting choice
then Bishop takes two to weigh five is
the move i'm going to present in my
upcoming book on the news on boo Union
this book project really is long overdue
simply because I had too much work on my
plate in the last couple of month but it
will be finished in the next couple of
weeks and certainly be released in the
first half of 2014 um yeah um okay let's
go to the game night it took on d to
check this is not all this won't be in
my book I'm concentrating on a five
Bishop e2 is a good line though as
mentioned it leads to somewhat
simplified positions because of the
exchange on detune and this line here is
very similar to the kettle on white
fianchetto like this is a new move 23
and black sets up this typical triangle
confirmation his intention is to
complete development with b6 Bishop d7
and the later c5 while the queen bee
finds a good post on e seven this is
very important feature of them exchange
on d 2 with the dark squared bishop
exchanged like has a good square only 7
4th Queen quite often the Queen black
screen as a it's a problem peace in
Queen porns openings because on the CND
file yeah see file and d4 very often
wide wide rocks putting pressure on
blacks position so you have to find a
place for the Queen where is not yeah in
danger of being being harassed and e7 is
a very good square for that this is also
reason why them the last Kaveri ation of
the Queens gambit is so solid black gets
a good square on his seventh for the
Queen and this is a bit a bit similar to
the last come in at least ur the from
from that the general spirit of the
opening okay quit c3 this is a new move
according to my database and it's an
interesting try by Van vini
queen is indirectly controlling me 5 so
that this free movie 65 is more
difficult to achieve it in this manner
is it similar to two of them fugitive
Bishop influence in the center the next
couple of moves are very logical as
mentioned this is blacks development
plan and Dwight expands on the queenside
this is also a benefit of the Queen on
c3 it supports this this move 85 yeah
blankets trying to exchange of the
queenside pants and ultimately with this
move he wants to activate the b7 Bishop
try to neutralize White's advantage on
this long diagonal this is the main
point very often of the Catalan the
bishop on g2 is a powerful piece and the
bishop being 1c8 is not so great and now
black wants to activate this piece so
that it ultimately can be exchanged yeah
wide exchanged on c5 ID took on c5 again
like this yeah and now I'm we come to a
position where I think like is pretty
close to being equal already if he
manages to exchange of those two pawns
and therefore open this diagonal you
shouldn't have any problems at all
however there are tactical issues of
course the opening of the Queen side now
leads to concrete play if white takes on
d5 like can you take with the Queen this
is no problem at all you need to cover
the night of course and black may even
play 94 later what he tried is Queen to
b4
attacking this night and looking at the
b7 Bishop blacks replies very obvious
night f.2d seven and now I plead Knight
d4 opening up the diagonal and making it
harder for black to take on c4 yeah rook
ba the very logical reply this covers
the bishop and again introduces the
possibility of taking on c4 yeah and now
it gets it gets a bit strange the
absolutely normal move here would be
actually to take on 75 something like
that for example of course this is a
completely equal position but there
there is not much that you can expect
him with both sides just a very very
equal however when really played the
move ruka 87 and while I understand the
idea black takes you're going to win the
peace the real issue of this movies the
reply Bishop a6 and this is what Knight
each plate it just text the Queen and
white does not have much choice you need
to retreat it and after Queen B 6 yeah
this queen is attacking the rook on a 7
and through Connors happiness just just
stranded it does not have any square so
on white just needs to give up the
exchange it's simply trapped and this is
quite a remarkable development because
it wasn't exactly difficult to spot this
idea it's hard to believe that when
veniam didn't didn't see the move Bishop
a 6 i'm not sure what his idea was
because right now he just took on a 786
there's nothing else and after Queen
takes and the capture on d5 twice we get
to a position where wide as an exchange
down he has some compensation for the
change in the very nice bishop on d5 and
he's also got still a very compact corn
structure instead he does not have any
additional pawn weaknesses on or any
other simple yeah point of attack
presenting to black but still it's an
exchange down and wide should be
struggling here for a while light it
sure does not make any any mistakes he's
improving his position slowly which is
certainly a good idea you don't need to
rush things here what he needs to yeah
yeah make his mind up about is those the
placement of the two nights the nights
here are not ideally placed they somehow
are tied to each other they are
protecting each other with this also
means they take away squares from each
other and they don't detect anything
they'd rather passive while those pieces
are active and it's not it's not so easy
to play for black it so that the type of
position where you you know where yeah I
should be better they exchange something
but how to actually play it's not so
easy he played look to be 6 which of
course makes some sense it's am
preparing a doubling of rooks like this
yeah look here like place rook to be too
which looks nice why just oops moves the
Queen away and this is not threatening
much this is securely protected
it's not so easy to make progress well
rock the six plate and now he for
supporting the strong bishop on d5 and
this Bishop cannot easily be attacked
like this because the c5 night is
hanging like this for example now he is
also a five so Knight b6 is really
useless smooth but what I'm trying to
show is that the c5 night is really a
slight liability yeah he played rook to
e8 controlling e5 and white went from
Quincy to be 6 back and now he 5 yeah
here black curve needed to to play the
correct move and then fact he he failed
to do so after you 5 he just he needs to
take only five this is just the central
movie needs to play after night xe5 swan
line Luke takes a five Queen takes oops
greentech c5 there's the cool rock to
the six pinning the bishop after which
black will get some material back for
example after after the shot at seven
the king is just retiring and here black
can still try to to win with the
exchange up it's not easy though I mean
just for example if white sets up
something like porn to h5 nightwear for
he is never ever going to lose the game
especially not with Queens on as blacks
King is so weak it's a very decent
chance for why to hold
but this is what he should have done
taking on e5 he played Queen to d8 and
get this it's a really big mistake it
leads to a complete disaster now and
there's even more than one possibility
for when ready to get a great position
the easiest is in fact or the most
convincing I'm not saying it it easy to
find but the most convincing is actually
knight c6 attacking the Queen and if the
Queen moves play quincy form and this is
a substantial threat against f7 like
really it's no way to save it cannot
play here for example because of yeah
taking first sorry taking first and then
you have this threat to 97 winning the
Queen it's very hard to check to save
that pong you can't play a rookie evade
but then when I d7 check King moves and
Bishop at seven and this is such a such
a terrible threat black is completely
busted yeah 96 was very strong when very
played the Queen f5 which is slightly
only slightly worse compared to 96 it
probably also wins the game but the
other one was a bit a bit more
convincing after after this move and
black play the Queen e7 to cover here he
played knight c6 after all and in here
neither chest the additional defense
Queen f8 which does not mean that this
is great for black but it wasn't
additional possibility note that the
Queen on f8 is completely out of squares
it's just a very passive defense of
peace yeah not ft form the good thing
about why its position is so easy to
play you just get all your pieces into
attacking mode this is protecting each
other 'if I've is protected and
like has so much pressure to stand on f7
this is just terrible note that you
cannot play g6 here because it's hanging
then easily miss that with little time
and why it has a very simple way to
improve the position we will see that in
the next move 9h played rugby too and
when very played rooks you three ridges
simply attending the rook left to have
three and after that f7 is collapsing
simple but very effective roxy three
yeah went went all the way back it's
it's pretty much hopeless to defend age
five just improving a little more if he
goes night and three here that's also
strong black probably please Knight b6
and you you retreat it's also excellent
for white but i like when various
movements very methodical what he tries
to do is to set up this battery against
h7 with bishop to be one Queen h7
checkmate and h5 just fixes the Queen
side so that g6 absolutely never
possible so good move age five they drew
Kade and now Luke see to back this is
the preparation for the mentioned
maneuver as we see here the maneuver
with them ok sorry I i miss the little
something after rook a one here the move
rookie to what when very played is is ok
but he had to leave it stronger
possibility that however is not at all
easy to calculate for human player the
computer of course is for frog buddha is
very easy but for humid it is not the
strongest smooth here what is six and
the point is
easy easy to miss after the capture well
okay you can also just take six which is
good but the computer finds of strange
idea tonight is heaven check Queen takes
now the only move and then 96 and this
is in fact absolutely crushing because
now white threatens multiple discovered
checks and black has no defense
absolutely no defense it's a calm
compass on on + 7 after just a couple of
seconds and probably with getting a bit
deeper in calculation this will even
increase um 11 point is the threat night
g5 check so if black plays nothing move
here let's say let's say yeah yeah
there's this check enormous check check
Nate with this point and yeah it just it
just completely gone but 97 is very
counterintuitive bishop is sexual other
also wins this was another good check
possibility winning easily he played
rookie to improving or he tries to
improve his position for him does
anything decisive that's worse though
it's not an immediate winner anymore 96
push of a 2 and here black probably
needed to retreat the night again played
a qui 28 and yeah this is ultimately
losing but i don't think that black had
much chances to survive this anyway this
Bishop be one who is the problem the sub
battery as the maid threat and black
needs to give up the exchange which she
did to convey one
plate night be to a 4 here's some
continuing the struggle but white is
just enjoying this extra porn more space
the better King position this is too
much he improves a bit further like that
after Queen c8 white is going for them
for the final check with the night being
transferred to f5 this is too much now
look before threatening luke t Eric p8
and if like now takes on c6 that's this
fog winning caplet Queen a six and now
after night fe7 nidus resigned this is
just too much of a threat if black takes
on c6 check there's rugby aid this is an
additional problem and white wins wins
everything probably a force made I
didn't didn't check that but you win all
pieces almost so I'm a very strange game
with van very being I guess a bit lucky
after he gave up the exchange for four
at first in sufficient compensation but
he got enough play 22 justified later
okay let's go to the next game domingues
against Wesley so here we go we have e 4
and we got the petrol for Russian
defence and dominguez place the 593 line
nowadays and probably the main line of
the Petrov it really has some become the
most popular line after years of D for
being the maintenance one point of this
is that
in this structure why it very often it
has a simple straightforward plan going
for King side attack I don't want to
focus too much on the details of the
opening White's general plays long
castles and then something like h4
Bishop d3 95 trying to attack the Kings
side so is playing the move b6 here I
guess this is not new but I'm not then
let's let's let's rephrase this i'm not
not an expert on the on the Petrov
really so I'm not a big authority here
but I I have the suspicion that this b6
plan is a bit slow I mean it shouldn't
lose the game or anything but this what
black is doing seems of the Ted slow to
me he's tried to regroup the night to
have six to defend we see that Bishop
whoops Bishop d3 and Knight to g5 and
domingues is playing Bishop d4 yeah this
activates the bishop putting some
pressure on the night and this type of
attack is is coming played c5 very
direct play gaining the bishop pair and
now Queen a form nearing the black yeah
putting the Queen near the black king no
g5 is an idea all the pawn pushes they
are all interesting play d5 yeah not
that certainly at this it looks logical
and now aged five looky 8ng for this is
all I think pretty logical play white is
as playing on the King side anyway so he
pushes pushes
the pawns there and now it's a black
stone he needs to defend precisely and I
think that even on let's say exactly the
next move that Wesley so is playing I
think exactly this move is already the
losing one it's um it's already very
tense this position he played g6 which
yeah it look always looks a bit weird to
to move upon in front of your king and
sort of present the opponent with some
some hook for an attack therefore g6 is
a bit of a strange move but it's very
difficult to look at this type of
position with any general consideration
moves are working or not working and g6
is not working probably what you should
have done is to play deform but let's
focus on what happened after g6 because
the punishment is really Swift and very
nice okay took on g6 and now g5
attacking the bishop it's retreating to
g7 and now if you want you can treat
this position as a puzzle try to find
the best attacking moves now form the
near dominguez from Cuba White's next
move is basically winning the game and
it's really nice okay I'm am quiet for a
couple of seconds so that you can pause
the video if you like treat it as a
puzzle okay the moves that white plate
now it's very nice rook age 70 this is
always funny to have the scan of rook
move right into the opponent's camp and
it's not capturing anything
this would be a nice move of white would
capture porn on h7 for example but it's
just putting the look right near the
opponent and sort of saying okay take it
take it yeah well of course if like like
takes it which you didn't didn't do that
if it takes there's Queen f7 and Luke
edge one such a big threat it's really
check made now checkmate in four moves
black can do this kind of desperado
moves like rookie one but basically Luke
edgemon checkmate is unavoidable now so
black cannot take the rook that is
relatively quickly to the spot but
what's the real issue get the issue is
that why does threatening just to play
look h1 tweenage for group h a checkmate
whoop g7 and so on it's just a tripling
of the H file and black is is really
helpless again that he played a deform
the move that he should have played a
bit earlier and white can simply respond
with Bishop c4 yeah threatening on f7
black Calot that and after this white
has amongst others this move this is
booz was played queen age to also whence
it was already a more than one book that
leads to win but this is a very direct
move it threatens rook takes 3-7 and
also look h1 which is the most direct i
guess if black takes just four for
example chess one check check check and
why does winning
this is too much this is the threat
Bishop f7 and queen h7 and queen edge a
check made absolutely no way to defend
it what is mating in a couple of moves
yet so black cannot take on f3 and there
simply is no booth this line that i just
showed it's just it's just one one
possible when if black would take here
for example check check just to show
there's also this one queen edge admit
unavoidable yeah it's a it's just a
deadly attack and it shows that in those
very very sharp positions with opposite
side castling just one move like g6 um
can can cost the game that it's really
too much now rupesh 7s just very strong
because it combines the threat of
doubling with rook takes g7 and black
has just just toast yummy yeah dominguez
is so having a good a good tournament he
could have been even more successful at
in some games and maybe really am can
cook a fight with the Aronian for the
title of this installment for the win
okay next game kayaking against Gelfand
yeah kayaking have known a so-so
tournament not brilliant but not
terrible and galfond is really having a
terrible he went he's not in good shape
at all and still we see that he's going
for the night off he's really a returned
to his old favorite the night off
Sicilian um he's also playing the
shashlik of course both very sharp
openings and for a while he also
championed the Petrov but Kuryakin has
an excellent score against the pressure
off so maybe this is also why he went
for one of his
sharper repertoire choices Gelfand
really unjustified the sir this opinion
sometimes has some reputation of being a
somewhat boring play I really not sure
why sometimes I read I read that and his
plane really sharp openings especially
with black okay the night off kayaking
place h3 a little move would favorite of
bobby fischer's fish are played it a
couple of times and it just prepares g4
as a sort of a somewhat slower carries
the tech and black responds with the
typical night of movie 5 after nine de
tu y its intention is to play G for
Nigeria Bishop g2 with this kind of
setup building up on the Kings side but
still keeping the option open of
castling short um delfin place the
professional room with age five really
interesting this this approach and it's
pretty typical for modern opening play
at the Sicilian where whites plan is
very often connected to the g4 advanced
and more and more we see that black
plays relatively early age 5 to prevent
g4 this is one case where this is some
pretty nowadays standard positional tool
yeah white is going from the king size
fianchetto this makes lots of sense b5
in Bishop g5 you try to increase control
over the d5 square 97 and all this looks
fairly logical to me
oopsie 8 yeah Oh quite normal um here
kayaking tape takes only seven this is a
decision that at first looks a bit
strange because the seven bishop is not
really looking like a great piece but of
course black was threatening to take on
d5 with material wins and what was
White's great moves beside night XD
seven he simply um needs to defend
against this night XD fire threat so he
took on his seven and continued with the
a good moons h4 h4 is interesting this
sir prepares amongst others to place the
bishop on h3 this makes lots of sense
because on h3 this Bishop is on a good
diagonal pinning and this type of
position is well known from other
openings where this night is pinned and
the bishop on let's back this we have
those two bishops pressurizing the
Knights and it very often leads to a
weakening of the porn structures a
capture of one of the Knights leads to
double pawns we see a this structure
rising in the game later he played 9 p-6
23 Quincy 7 and Bishop h3 here we go and
in fact I think that here is one point
where where girl phone can improve he
played rock to be eight just going away
from the attack of the bishop um I think
he should have played that ft 7 I know
that this is not
I move that you probably play with great
enthusiasm but in the game which is the
alternative after the move why it took
on f6 and I don't really like the
structure of course if you play the rash
new golf fuel you are sort of used to
having slightly fishy porn structures on
the King side but the problem is that
here you also have h5 plate and it's
very difficult to imagine where blacks
King in the long run will find a safe
haven it's very difficult if the Pawn
would still be on age 7 you could
imagine that blankets maybe even
castling short but this is completely
impossible with the pawn on h5 and I
really don't like blacks position here
long castles be 495 white could also
consider to play a 3 instead of long
castles but i don't i don't think that
this was a mistake he just transposase
to a different pawn structure now now we
have the bishop trade not immediately
but it will happen and why detects the
mentioned we can pawn structure with
therefore and always think about your
king position whereas black skin going
to find a safe spot it's very difficult
to find one simply because so many ponds
have leased and have left weaknesses in
your camp while the White King on c1 is
completely secure can even do this
typical prophylactic sidestep to be one
and then it has a perfect porn cover and
it's just perfectly safe and um yeah
well this is the real problem here like
him has not I think does not have enough
dynamism in the position to justify a
sum his bed structure and bad King have
the straight and king of eight he's
trying to get it to g7
why took and now with rook edge to this
rook enters the game again we have a
good and simple attacking plan on the F
file around here wide must be in
excellent shape played King g7 we have
to Andrew page six and around here I
must admit that I'm a bit surprised at
about not add about the next couple of
moves I really would have expected wyd
to to focus on all the King cytotec
playing something like rook d to
everyone here and just try to be a to
breakthrough on the Kings side I don't
know maybe f6 is necessary and then you
have various ideas look at five g-form i
don't know i mean i would have focus on
the Kings side but kayaking is doing
something entirely different it just
grabs the pond I'm not saying that it's
a bad movement had the computer just
prefer as Queen Essex but I'm not sure I
like the general idea to grab material
now when he could have just happened
attack without any particular
counterplay Galvan played be three I
captured on b3 with rook using the pen
so what can not take of course ya know
ki can continues with Quincy six this it
seems um what's the idea and maybe him
he didn't appreciate the the response
and I'm not sure that
he willingly got into the position that
arises now he queen SMS Calvin smooth
and in fact after the upcoming
transformation i don't think the
position is so clear he now took on f7
getting at least upon upon for for the
rook and the capture by the way it's not
good at all here it's even questionable
if it is still something for white black
has immediate ideas as well this is why
you just grab this pawn and then took on
b3 if we do a simple body count here why
does porn up but a to pawn sorry two
parts even but it's not a matter of
quantity of the time but also of quality
the G porn is not really doing much at
the moment it is hemmed in by the h5
form and white has to be pawns in itself
not too great this double porn and the
beep on being a passer is very yeah very
far away from Queenie I don't think that
this position is so clear actually and I
think Gavin could have defended much
better in the next couple of moves there
are alternatives for both sides but I
think in general it was it was ok like
try to stay active yeah I hear not
reading queens of course which would
very much improved White's chances the
White King now I in all this term is
also weakened a lot in comparison to to
before when only blacks King was
yup t3 covering here no girl from play
droog f6 and King be one try to secure
the King a bit young and exactly here I
think is the the real problem girl
fancier place King and sorry king queen
g1 check and this seems to help wyd
enormously he probably should have
played Queenie to with the idea to
activate the rook here or look f1 and
then then Queen back this is some it
seems like this according to the
computer tougher defense and I'm not
sure that this is saving black or
anything but it's tough tougher than
what he / she ate as much he gave the
check and now um King a to its it's
difficult now how should black proceed
white check gets the King to be three
and this is really helpful the king is
relatively safe here and in fact white
is close to just advancing the porn he
played them Luke f1 and now Luke f3
here black only had one pin so he only
had one move still not the saving move
but he needed to to trade him what he
did is he played the UK one this looks
like a logical move trying to harass the
king but in fact after Queen III simple
but very effective why does threatening
Queen g5 check and yeah black can give
give this check on a forum on a two but
after booth moves let's say he shot the
skins history and there's no check here
the important c1 squares protected the
Queen does not have any check and after
oops Archer this is just the same
there's no check for black and white is
winning with this decisive threat this
means that after Queen III girlfriend
must trade Queens and she did that
unfortunately this is now a complete win
as the be porn is supported by the King
now if the King would be further down
it's a different story but he had this
very simple technical play why just wins
easily black only can charge the pawns
the only source of some count to five
and here we get to this typical position
the rook is covering on the fourth rank
and it's stopping the black king from
doing anything active and why just uses
the king not quite sure why I'm going
why Eddie to kikit goats ago he of
course and use the king to push the beep
on and this is what happens check here
we go check
check yeah and this is now very clear
covering everything like only continued
a couple of more moves and now resigned
this is just completely hopeless if it
goes before chatters this check and
white takes the phone yeah this is an
easy win now we can yeah winning in
various ways even you can probably the
easiest technically is to get the H
ponent win with the two connected passes
but you can also probably just promote
the beep one yeah galphin is just just
in bad shape in this tournament in this
type of very concrete sharp position um
a small misstep in calculation can
easily cost the whole game at this was
happening here so Goodwin and porn went
for kayaking but girl firdous just yeah
further further losing rating points
here with really having a bad event okay
next game theory against Aruna huronian
is in the lead of course and giving us
one of them pursuers and win of course
would would help him enormously let's um
let's check the game we have a Catalan
opening again aronian playing the Queens
gambit declined and 11 slight thing to
notice that he is going for the Queens
gambit declined why are the night f 66
move order which is nothing spectacular
this is the most common move order
nowadays but it also shows that aronian
has switched a bit of his move orders
earlier let's say two years ago one even
one year ago he was very often going to
the Queens gambit
this move order and he lost quite a
number of games and the exchange
variation here this type of exchange
against nakamura against cards and and
so on he really didn't have a good score
and it seems that he hasn't been that
the smooth order in favor of going oops
in favor of starting with Knight f6 andy
sixx therefore including the NIMS o in
his repertoire but after 93like here
going to the Queens gambit okay slight
detour to the details of operating prep
okay g3 we have the catch alone again
popular choice nowadays very safe
opening aronian is playing the main line
and this has been his defense against
the Catalan for for ages and he rarely
loses with this with the opening um wins
once in a while but mostly he used it as
he uses it to to to draw which is
general okay for black of course Quincy
to a six and now give me playing a 4
here we already have seen in this
tournament also Quincy form or Avon f4
keeps a bit more pieces on the board and
the general is less of a technical
continuation were very natural
developing moves black has activated his
problem Bishop with a deed has activated
it via d76 very important and have good
development here and
yeah here black I think has a pretty
pretty decent position this has been
been played before and black um gap has
more than one good setup he's going for
Queenie seven this is further
strengthening control over the before
square and white cannot really play that
with he's going form for trades yeah
this is in fact an interesting reply the
most obvious one actually would have
been to take and then yeah go for a free
moves like see 5 or a 5 I think that
this also was very close to being equal
but Bishop t5 is an interesting
alternative it's simply attacking the
Queen but obviously address the Queen
supposed to go you don't really have a
great square he decided to take it at
the end and we have this transformation
where white got the d5 pawn black got d
to pawn its material equal but 94 now is
attacking the bishop and her own yard is
just accepting yeah after a couple of
temple gains and now giri is playing for
to continue the game what their own is
doing is accepting a position where
white has some pressure against those
pawns and okay at the moment he's got an
extra porn but this is not a very yeah
very um yeah durable fact it's just very
quickly happening that black is going to
lose one of the pawns and he is somewhat
worse because white has more activity
but let's say
rupee 8 look everyone yeah it's not a
spectacular move but where to go you
don't want to exchange and give like
immediate counterplay this is why we
have one was played Queenie for and now
we get to the total rook endgame those
are somewhat weaker then d4 d5 therefore
white has some edge but I don't think
it's a serious one the computer is
giving white quite something but I don't
really believe it Black is is too active
to be in real trouble and we see that
with rupee form he is quickly gaining
counter play now this is a counter play
that black is going for would be six and
Roxy too in fact there are some tricks
of this position that are quite
remarkable rook to e3 and g5 in this
position how would you assess the move
route takes a 64 white if you want a
little puzzle try to calculate the
consequences of route takes a 6 i'll
give you a couple of seconds to pause
the video yeah what do you think about
Luke a six what happens after the smooth
yeah the fun fact is that after he won
check kingi to this G form and this
position is not not even a draw for
white he's just losing due to the rook
see one thread look see one and rook g1
checkmate Black has no defense
absolutely no defense against that he is
just flat-out losing after h3 there's h5
and black simply is going for this
meeting attack white cannot defend
against it his roofs are so badly placed
that you have no way to prevent mate or
the loss of four oops or something
it is just just lost so rook takes a six
is not on he played age three and now
aged five of course again Luke a six is
losing to check to that one so you
played rook a three even try to get for
some counter play or intending ruge f5
yeah f g4 and repair phone yeah black is
also taking d for this is why he covered
takes Andrew k2 at the end white
actually managed to get the a six porn
but in the process we see that like has
this active rook and he's got this king
activation I don't think white has any
serious winning chances here and in fact
in the game we see that aronian really
check really easily manages to draw gets
the King into the game here threatening
some counter play ideas check now again
and now the King returns to stop or help
stopping the pawns here's the counter
play group III check also check yeah we
get up yeah because here could have
taken f5 of course but after okay six we
get to completely drawn rook endgame
white can win the porn but of course
black is controlling the game easily
being in front of the pawn this was
played and I in fact he ain they they
drew there's simply no progress to be
made white also cannot get the King into
the play
Jeff to his is hanging yeah I think
aronian um didn't really am was he
didn't really have a big problem see it
was slightly inconvenient but I don't
think white had any direct winning
chances so it gets pretty pretty okay
draw him and he keeps the lead by that
draw of course okay next game kawana
against report creative Hungarian and I
actually start played through the moves
without seeing the complete score sheet
and I try to I was thinking okay let's
see ad which move is he going to play
some crazy line that no one is going to
expect and it was relatively quickly
here on your form yes I went for this a
very very uncommon sup variation of the
Rubenstein French it looks a bit weird
especially if you compare it to the
Bronstein lazem caricom where we have a
similar idea but there the porn is on e
7 and the pawn is closed not here on c6
typical chemical structure here the
bishop 1c8 is is just looking at the
city year six bond and just looks like a
very bad version of the mansion opening
but there is a difference and we see
this rather quickly 93 and he plays
knight c6 and this is the difference of
course you can develop the night
actively and even think about a movie 65
in
in some positions in fact I think that
koalas next move is not precise he
probably should play something like
Bishop e3 young or Bishop d3 he played
Bishop f4 and him black has a good reply
funny enough he can play and didn't play
is 65 it's a it's always a bit
embarrassing you play a move like Bishop
f4 like I'm controlling the five square
nicer and then tell me five is played
anyway the point is that after D takes
d5 that Quran I didn't even play after
the text e5 black has the move Queen is
happen and this is just good mean is
threatening or intending to play F takes
d5 and white really has no a good move
to prevent that he can yeah you can play
something like we need to protecting v5
but then there's oops not this chat then
there's this big check here for awesome
should be too and after Queen B to like
it's just an excellent shape so it can
take with check but there should be six
and long castles with an excellent
position the queen is really silly only
two now yeah it's a it's really a bit a
bit of an embarrassment that if I've was
possible but Kara wanna just retreated
to e3 and it continues the game it's not
a big big problem however Bishop f4
certainly wasn't the best move in this
position black went for Bishop g4 and
our Bishop to b5 around here maybe there
are some improvements for black I mean
you need to start to look for some
improvements because only a couple of
moves later blackest and serious trouble
and I don't believe he should be because
Bishop f4 allowing if I've certainly
wasn't the most
continuation here possible or
interesting line is Queen to d5 this is
a very complicated though and not easy
to assess over the board um especially
considering see form after which Queenie
for of course must be played and I think
that this is in fact quite okay for
black but it is complicated I'm not 100%
sure that my rather brief analysis is
really exhausted here one point yes of
course that d 5 which looks like a good
pin is answered by long castles and of
course white cannot take and the move
like Bishop c6 check yeah note the
various pins iam it's leading to get
disaster yeah white must be cautious
here and I can play move like Age 3 for
example bishop age five and now consider
various continuations can simply take if
you want keeping it relatively simple
but looked yet for example it's
certainly acted like I don't think he
needs to be afraid of this position at
all maybe 25 was a good good way to
plain he played the Queen d6 preparing
long castles as well but it's not
gaining a tempo of course I mean okay
this is also the threat but Queen d5
wasn't think just a bit better see three
boats during the center and keeping
queen before out of the game yeah here
he played the most evil again even if
it's a tempo down 25 was interesting but
a human is not going to play Queen d6
and then continuing 25 not
not very human this decision he played a
form but this definitely definitely
needs the trouble and because of two
things I mean one thing is what Kara
wanna plate um which is probably not
optimal but still okay the other thing
is d5 it's a a direct line that I think
needs to travel from like it's basically
forced now to yeah I think it's almost
forced to take him after the capture
then be six um white just is better in
this position for various reasons or
various moves again for instance play g3
and i know this is looking very funny
but the main problem is in the long run
that white will have the better king and
he's got very good chances in the
structure to a Texas c7 porn well black
has no comparable counter play against
f2 if we see this kind of configurations
being almost symmetrical this was
interesting d5 probably needing to to a
wide edge he played h3 which also led to
wide edge but only because um reports
now took on a three I think it probably
should have retreated after ninety two
white is also better but I think it's
less dramatic than the the position that
that he got in the game just have a look
what happened he took as mentioned takes
here takes g2 I drove g1 and here we can
see that the g2 pawn is doomed it will
be taken in very short order then we
have materially quality but in a
position where white is got two bishops
and the better pawn structure and the
better King at least them in a couple of
moves white one scheme will be more
secure
and this is just not the satisfactory
position from black we quickly see that
is in really big trouble yeah what has
gotten the porn back and what exactly is
blacks play it's very difficult to to
find any active possibility the two
points here are easily stopped by the g4
and oops nope this also applies for the
h-bond it also cannot move as lancha
stakes it's a it's just not good to this
position for black plates 95 and after
Bishop reform after Kincaid there should
be two in fact in this position black
went four for drastic measures he simply
decided that passive move was not it's
not working and decided to give up the
b7 porn and one problem of course is
let's say let's say you want to protect
the d5 night with the move like c6 yeah
this is not going to work in the long
run because of this kind of ideas c4
Bishop f4 yeah like ass in trouble he
played not be 6 giving up the b7 porn in
order to after Bishop d7 plane I'd see
form trying to to irritate white but
Kara wanna is doing a really good job to
just keep every yeah keep keep his
position on were coordinated so black
does not get any good counter play rugby
too so very easy I queen bee to queen
bee to answer by rope you want us a very
easy to see and yeah they try to to get
some play but it really didn't work out
can just just take everything check
yeah why does I think two points up yeah
two pawns but not only that look at the
structure and look at the King White's
king is relatively safe he has little
porn cover but he's got lots of pieces
around it and black does not really have
any counter play against the king yeah
this is now a fairly fairly easy
demonstration by coyoacán using the
rooks before one threat after this he
resigned report resigned many ways to
win 11 funny line is if black let's say
let's let's do is remove this is stupid
assume you take it let's say let's say
that this that's just Queen asics yeah
this is awesome also when of course
checkmate funny made yeah this is some
just a very very smooth bin phone kawana
against report yeah his creative opening
players once in a while really leading
leading him into trouble or at least it
leads to position positions where you
cannot afford to make any second-rate
decision like here nothing Queen d6
almost certainly led to trouble with the
Queen d5 it is an interesting position
however this only was possible because
Bishop f4 was a bit bit of a sub-optimal
move because of a five yeah so good win
for koala he's fighting for the for the
top standings with this win and report
losing me yet another game I don't think
he's completely I set
I'd with this event reports it's just
new for him to play this kind of tough
opposition and opposition and I think
it's not a bad thing that he's trying to
fight with all opponents and trying to
play creatively sometimes you see
younger players who get to to play this
very strong events for the first time
playing in a young more fat passer
fashion not try to really fight trying
to draw many games not losing many games
he's just fighting and try and try his
best so I'm certainly an interesting
player to watch okay one game left
harikrishna against Nakamura let's go to
that one we have a Sicilian the camera
are probably aiming for the night off
but check there should be five checking
yeah that's how the Sicilian has played
nowadays very often you get sidelines
and all the work you maybe have invested
in your favorites dragon on NYE dwarf
it's very often just useless because
they go for sidelines and they are not
really bad those sidelines my camera is
playing 97 this is one of the fighting
moves Bishop d7 is the the main main
moves here with literally pretty good
equalizing chances but it's also not a
move that you can can really fight with
it's very very dull sometimes they're
497 harikrishna castles and after a six
you place the funky move Bishop d3 you
yeah this is recently become popular
there are some
a game calzon against him I think it was
a bit low I'm trying to remember from
which tournament I don't think it was
the candidates or was it no it was not
the candidates of course the white game
against Videla was the final wrong game
that man was lost this will pass ok so
it was some from some other tournament
last year I think it was the Norway
tournament the star Wonga tournament ok
what I'm getting at is Bishop d3 while
looking a bit strange placing it in
front of the deep one it is has some
idea of course and we see this later
let's say quite quite here why does
regrouping the bishop to see two and
intending deform in fact the solid
structure if you look at this is very
similar to the to the Lopez it's only a
bit different in terms of Tempe invested
black as the night on g7 very often in
the Rue Lopez for instance in the briar
variation you have to play knight c6
back to be eight and then to d7 in fact
looking at this all this is totally
standard this position is some very
similar to the Brier um maybe I should
have pulled up the the position from the
way to check the exact difference
because there's not a huge difference
why does not played a tree for example
yeah what are what are the plans some
maybe we should put up text move 26 and
b3 yeah here there are various plans
possible the beauty of the rillo pass
for both scholars that there are so many
plans available and so many
transformations of the pawn structure
is happening or need to be considered
all the time yeah blackham has some one
natural break in this position and this
is f 5 the typical Kings India type of
break but note that it is super
difficult in this position to achieve
simply because white has so many pieces
on there five square at the bishop on b7
s not exactly well placed for that so
you don't have a very active poem break
f5 is not realistic what is black
supposed to do you normally you try to
improve your position a bit by going for
a see form for instance playing 95 you
sometimes can try to exchange the bishop
on f8 Maya h6 these are plants that
black and go for and white has more than
one plan he can try to attack the Queen
side with a phone combine that with
Bishop d3 pressurizing v5 I can try to
play on the Kings side for example
especially in the Royal position where
h3 is played you can play age 39 edge 2
and F form going for this break and in
in the game we quite quickly get the
prices on the queenside as Nakamura is
playing 96 will be one and then c4 he
immediately goes for some play on the
queenside this is very typical of his
play he does not really like it much to
to employ a sit and wait strategy of
course this in general applies for most
modern top players they don't like to
stay put much and just keep the position
as is trying to outmaneuver outweigh the
opponent this does not happen so often
they always try to play actively I'm not
sure that really this really has a great
decision but he does not want to stay
stay passive takes and therefore this is
why I think this may be a debatable
decision
b5 is a weakness and black very quickly
now goes for porn sec it's almost
impossible to keep the poor now he gave
it up like that and played night a three
maybe this was some the plan all along
with c4 after this the alternative was
to take here but how do you keep the
poor now I guess you don't so look back
and takes so far the pawn black has
managed to get this important see to
Bishop the Spanish bishop and he's got
the bishop am but I don't really believe
that this is such a great compensation
certainly because this bishop okay you
can activate that but what I going to do
with the f8 bishop this is simply a
rather passive piece and it's not easily
activated it feels a bit like a purely
defensive pawn sacrifice try to maybe
locate the Queen side and activate the
bishops later I don't I don't think it's
entirely unplayable but it's not
something that Nakamura would probably
repeat if he has the the position again
so after 97 and there should be three
like activates the bishop as mentioned
one pair of Lucas's is exchanged all
this is fairly logical Queen c8 and the
h3 it's not so easy for white to make
them any very concrete progress because
this is quite nicely blockaded stop but
I think why does still enjoying an easy
easy game
after 96 and this activation 90 mph 6 we
reach a critical position of the game um
yeah what should I can do I do now it
seems that he needs to react to White's
attacking idea to play like this in IG 5
or night h5 those moves are are
interesting and in fact night h5 as a
threat that he fails to address he
should have played here prepared getting
rid of this active rook after the
capture it may be why can't you see em
something like that White is better
simply because of the pawn here maybe
should should also win this in the long
run possibly but it's something that you
still can try to defend this black what
he played is a Quincy five looking like
an active move but it's just losing
instantly due to this this strong reply
as mentioned this was a threat but it is
a thread that Nakamura didn't really
address and the big point is of course
after Queen a seven then just check and
Bishop f8 and it's just this move
followed by Queen eh7 that is completely
impossible to defend against black can
just just resign in this position night
h5 he tried Bishop g7 very desperate
move Bishop takes and now taking here
because now of course our child check
black takes on g7 and winds but there is
an alternative of course just tweenage 6
yeah and here
oops sorry the big threat is Knight f6
check made of course so if he takes on
age 5 it's not g5 threatening mid so at
the end he played the move f5 which I
ever after 95 this is not safe it's
quite funny to see that white has this
cluster of attacking pieces and queen
age 7 check meters simply unavoidable
the only moves to avoid the immediate
made other computer stay desperado will
show that that led wine take to get to
move longer to to checkmate so I'm
Nakamura is continuing to to have a bad
tournament here I don't know somehow he
he he's got this record rating 2789 and
he he had this this rating not sure but
one year ago or so he had or just one or
two points below that and then he had to
had some bad events and lost lost all
those points again and somehow we have
the same situation here he was really
nearing the 2800 mark and now with this
tournament is going to do so many points
as he would this rating should have had
an event with let's say plus 2 or plus
free um points to be expected and now
he's on minus two of them not mistaken
if naught minus three I think it's minus
2y I wouldn't need to look it up but
he's really having a bad event losing
her many points and a nice veneer for
Hari Krishna but not not a difficult
night h 5 ER certainly move that he that
he quickly spotted or even had planned
before and of course
yeah we had a really good round again
with five decisive games all wide wins
and only one drove by geary and Iranian
all games interesting so a good event
tomorrow we have another rest day so I
have no coverage tomorrow but i will
return with more coverage from tatoski
around nine then on Thursday the
twenty-third if i'm not mistaken thanks
for watching